les cherry on continue avec une nouvelle
actu / wheels nef la plateforme netflix
a suspendu le tournage d'un des films où
l'acteur devait jouer la raison la gifle
qu'il a donnée à chris rock le maître de
la cérémonie des oscars voilà et donc
alors de quel film s'agit-il regardez
vous rendez compte terminer nos simbin
permis terminée
[Musique]
depuis sa gifle donnée à chris rock les
conséquences en chaîne pour will smith
alors il a été contraint de démissionner
de l'académie des oscars ce week-end
voilà que l'acteur pourrait perdre de
gros contrats tout d'abord avec netflix
qui a suspendu la production de son film
fast and blues dans lequel il devait
jouer un agent secret qui perd la
mémoire
will smith a vu sa collaboration avec
netflix pour le film fast and ou
suspendus après avoir frappé chris rock
mais aussi avec sony qui a choisi de son
côté de freiner le tournage de la suite
du film bad boys dans lequel l'acteur
avait le rôle principal
un coup dur pour la star d'hollywood qui
a déjà tourné dans près d'une
cinquantaine de longs métrages
[Musique]
sa merci meriam palombes à d'être avec
nous qu'est ce qui se passe ça vous tue
ça m'est insupportable
cette société de donneurs de leçons de
donneurs d'exa leur dit pas s'agira des
noyers
non mais moi je suis désolé les valeurs
que véhiculent louis smith reste de très
bonne valeur bah oui on maquille
respecter c'est un héros américain moi
je suis désolé tu vas tu vas tu a bloqué
un film alors que c'est will smith 6
pour une gifle je dis pas que c'est bon
mais franchement faut arrêter on dirait
qu'il a si vous êtes un ballon
alors bien la balle les infos alors ce
qui est d'ailleurs celle de temps mais
je vous en prie il a pris les devants
parce que tout meeting d'emmanuel
manqueront certainement pas non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est la question à l'époque supposent
les regarde à la télé et j'ai regardé d
eiffage oui j'ai un peu regardé pour le
faire vous avez trouvé formidable
cette femme a jeu l'adorent mais sa
femme c'est ça les gens gentils et ils
ont fait parce qu'il vient pour là je
sais pas ce qu'ils vous ont fui le pays
m'ont privé pendant deux ans de mairie
alors
c'est juste un match
une chance à ne jamais regarder je suis
devenu semaine des prénoms les manuels
régime marlène et là il ne travaille pas
directement
je me mets dans la mise à vous maîtrisez
khyber alors vous avez c'est pas elle a
ainsi on jette fred pour dimanche
prochain pour les élections oui ça vous
savez que votre choix sans nous le dire
on veut pas le savoir
j'hésite encore mais c'est vrai que ce
sera papa pour la première fois de ma
vie sera pas un vote de conviction ah
oui on allait tout sauf ce sera tout
sauf un le tout sauf donc tout sauf que
jean lassalle
d'aujourd'hui allez on y va alors est
sûre si will smith alors tout ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que clairement il a pris
les devants en annonçant par par
communiqué de presse qu il le
démissionné de l'académie puisque le 18
avril une grande assemblée était est
prévue par l'académie des oscars et il
devait de toute façon le virer à ce
moment là puisque même si effectivement
on peut dire que will smith est dans son
rôle de dom prévenant le fait qu'il est
quand même frappé chris rock reste
quelque chose d'insupportable pour
beaucoup il a été énormément critiqué
par jim carrey mandy moore voilà il ya
toutefois la ja il ya tout un tas
d'erreurs qui se sont offusqués
effectivement la crête demi dsk ne peut
pas accepter de tels de tel ton pince il
avait mille juifs dans la rue
oui ça serait pas non je pense à moi si
je rencontre quelqu'un
serait pas pareil on dit mais bon la
société américaine étant ce qu'elle est
on peut pas donner une gifle comme ça
les françaises c'est sympa ce nom ne
serait pas passé mais ce serait donc
j'ai donné une gifle à quelqu'un ce sera
que ça voulait va là non
j'ai déjà assez dormi mais je peux vous
le dire non mais c'est pour vous montrer
sage et pendant que vous ayez des ennuis
nation que son contrôle ou suivent vous
trouvez que ça vous trouvez ça normal
géraldine non mais tu sais pas ne sait
pas que c'est normal c'est une gifle et
c'est exit en fait moi je trouve que
c'est il s'est excusé maintenant qu'il a
démissionné franchement je trouve que ça
lui réussit et sauf qu'aujourd'hui il ya
le diktat des plateformes aujourd'hui
netflix amazon disney apple et c'est
elles qui décident elles ont fait 50
milliards de dollars de revenus l'année
dernière mais en fait c'est bien une kg
chine et elles ont tellement peur d'un
bad buzz ce au cas où si jamais
éventuellement il y avait trois
personnes qui se plaignaient main mais
c'est elle qui décide aujourd'hui mais
marc dulude donc du coup elles ont
décidé et donc ils ont l ol ont écarté l
on extrait voilà point barre il fait
pareil pour turny d'être absolument sûr
johnny depp castaldi qui est plus on
ne peut pas commander un truc sur amazon
il a demandé durée et il a commandé du
dodo nord du 2e rang d'une artère la
semaine dernière il a reçu du haut bas
haut de sa gueule non mais vous venez
donc ça des problèmes de l'harcèlement
de violence de violences sexuelles et
tout ça quand il y avait un kevin spacey
tout ça qui l'avait écarté qui me dis
pas ici ses bras au sort car mais là
franchement je trouve que déjà voilà il
s'est excusé ils venaient dans quel état
wells mais ça il va pas bien et puis
surtout ils regrettent certains noms
c'est dingue parce qu'il a eu un oscar
et le mec m'a pas mais non mais oh great
et puis en plus c'est vrai qu'il s'est
quand même fait monter le bourrichon par
sa femme donc voilà oui ça fait vraiment
ah bah oui c'est sa femme qui est
derrière tout ça si sa femme ne lui
avait pas fait s'ils ne l'avaient pas
voilà la chauffe un peu allez allons
vraiment chauffer
il a dû faire près parce qu elle l a pas
soutenu après non c'est à dire qu'elle
est pas comme une folle sur lui non en
fait on connaît tous un peu la relation
que le couple à la chanson libre c'est
j'adore voilà ça couple libre elle elle
a eu des aventures avec d'autres hubs
des hommes même plus jeune que will lui
il ya quand même toute une rumeur comme
quoi en fait il serait bisexuelle et
aurait eu des aventures avec
ddd garçons donc voilà c'est un couple
libre et d'ailleurs il en parle très
ouvertement dans les médias c'est pas
quelque chose d'accord ouais ouais mais
simon sez le couple balle let bat le
coup bas de laine depuis des années et
c'est aussi un peu pour ça qu'il a réagi
aussi de façon aussi virulente parce
qu'il voulait montrer que voilà il était
unie face à l'adversité et aux moqueries
de chris rock oui nicolas pernikoff fait
d'accord avec cette sanction je crois je
suis d'accord avec cette sanction et
géraldine je suis pas d'accord avec toi
il ya de la rancoeur et ce que j'ai
assez vite c'est vrai il s'est excusé
quelques minutes après il ne l'a pas
fait c'est alain vertu trouve que
l'image allait quand même déplorable
puisqu'on veut toujours un exemple les
déplorables pour été spectateur devant
la télé ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose est ce que vous imaginez
chris rock personne ne parle de lui il
est le mec il a le cran a assuré
sur hegel en direct et de continuer
l'émission comme si de rien n'était je
veux dire regardez là j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle jean lassalle depuis
toulouse nous fait un gros bisou ainsi
qu'à tous nos chroniqueurs jeu j'adore
ce mec là je le dis et et j'espère
j'aimerais tellement qu'il fasse plus de
5% dans la salle presque sur 5 % ils
auront pour c'est sa compagne est
remboursé ils le méritent tellement
j'espère vraiment j'espère qui va les
faire oui la vision de nicolas pernikoff
est totalement malhonnête quant à myriam
palombes à qui est scandaleusement de
disloquer le couple louis smith
barney smith n'en fasse pas passer
l'aubaine excuse moi mais si vous
connaît
oui je suis
actuellement unis vers des zones facture
qu'il a même entendu fatou dans le
discours fois que la mienne j'ai froid
qu'il arrive entendu fat ou non l
arctique modifié avec lui parce que on
l'a obligé j'ai lu la lettre qu'on l'a
obligé à écrire j'avais l'impression
d'un otage qui sous la contrainte doit
être une excuse non mais c'est vrai que
la lettre qu'on oublie s'il a envie
l'ambition moi vous voulez que je vous
dise la lutte aurait pas fait non jours
maintenant aux oscars ah oui tu plonges
cas je peux aux oscars tu en a [ __ ] et
laisse en effet la méritoire des
statuettes chez moi et voir s je m'en
fous je vais disney j'achète d'aider les
petites statuettes des données de mickey
et c'est tout tu vends de leur chien et
corps oscars a paru sans déconner smith
sait pas pourquoi il a été écrit cette
lettre tamines flow gîte amine
flaugère oscars oui mais vas-y
[Applaudissements]
borloo
même aux états unis à des pernikoff ya
des palombes acquis et les on dit
mais ce n'est pas les saisies avec ce
qui nous oppose ramadan parce que
justement on voudrait bien faire mes
adieux travaux aux états unis voilà
donc aux états unis ramadan dans la rue
nous on avait du radoub
un soir de shabbat en plus je l' ai vécu
très très mal
il sortir dans la rue moi aussi oui
alors oui on non mais moi je l'avais dit
ici quand tu parles de la lettre tu dois
fallait pas faire de l'être moi j'avais
dit ce qu'il fallait qu'ils fassent il
fallait qu'ils se lèvent s'il veut
mettre la gifi là mais il prend sa
famille ce bar au lieu de ça il est
resté il a assisté à la cérémonie
ensuite il a chialé final rien oscars il
a fait la fête après il assume
maintenant aujourd'hui moi ça me fait de
la peine parce que bad boys 4 qu'est ce
que ça veut dire quoi moi je l'attends
le film là il va pas être la cause de
ces conneries quand il aura dû attendre
chris rock en rang loges ils lui dirent
ne parle plus jamais de ma femme comme
ça
la fête de la saucisse oui a défendu sa
fan numéro 2
comment exactement
avec la plus grosse la gueule il a
raison il a raison mais moi
moi moi je dois y joue un jour être un
truc cette lettre qu'il arrive des flux
à oui c'est quoi cette lettre la maison
mais aussi les îles à présent
c'est de finir au bond et côté dacquois
il est boycotté bon côté
il est bon écouter non mais non non non
je rigole hervé joly et will smith qui
payent trop cher et moi je pense il a
mis à lui il aurait dû et rochers en
allemand alors l'autre s'il veut faire
un procès il va voir qu'ils écrivent une
lettre à chris rock ou un mois chris
rock mais qui écrivent un mot aux oscars
mais vas-y mais penneteau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tous à vos masques a
juste suffi qu'il met en avant la
légitime défense le mec il a défendu sa
femme il méritait de bosser parce que
non mais là j'imagine je comprends les
gens qui disent que c'était dans ma
carrière c'est la lettre là les rêves
dire non tu vas voir le mec tu t'excuses
et chris rock chris rock qui dit écoutez
c'est bon c'est parler et faire payer ou
non tu t'excuses pas le mec il a insulté
sa femme carla des
secours même si ce pour mettre des temps
de s'excuser je mange année j'y fais des
gens là bas je m'excuse mais ce que j
-ph quelqu'un tu t'excuses pas tu vois
au bout c'est fait avec toi tu te rends
compte le monde dans lequel on m'a vite
si maintenant on va se lâcher dans le
monde dont gifle pas manqué de surgir un
mensonge il agit il fait devant tout le
monde après il pleure on va manger des
petits fours et après la bascule mois
après
une lettre non
dix moutons et gbagbo si manning
wasquehal et c'est bon c'est bon on a
compris inquiète pas les valter non mais
ils vont s'arranger jouer a prévu
d'aller voir avec mon jeu
mon fils a pas tarder à nous faire chier
va